Speaker 1: I want to start with something kind
of funny today. Steve Doocy is one of the three
hosts of the Fox News morning show Fox and
Friends. And over the last 6 to 12 months,
occasionally steve doocy has had these strange
moments of clarity where he will interject a fact
or an actually sort of interesting analysis about
a political situation. Usually his hosts look
kind of confused about the fact that he's rather
than propagandizing, just saying something that's
uncontroversial is true. And of course, we're left
to speculate about what's going on. Is a do sees
sort of private little way of rebelling against
the disinformation spread on Fox and Friends,
or is it just that he stumbled across a fact which
happens sometimes very on thsporadically on Fox
News? Who knows? These clips are from the decoding
Fox News Twitter account, who does a really good
job in this clip talking about most of these clips
are related to the 2024 Republican primary, which
is increasingly an interesting topic on Fox News
because Fox News is sort of trying to figure out
what is our position going to be? Are we going to
be overtly pro-Trump or are we going to be subtly
pro-Trump or are we going to be subtly anti-Trump
in the sense that we will not talk about Trump the
most, or will we choose a particular candidate
other than Trump, like DeSantis or others,
to attach ourselves to and try to really promote
that candidate? It's not clear the direction Fox
News will go yet, but here is Steve Doocy stating
something I talked about on the Wednesday show,
which is when you look at polling in May
or June of the year before the primary,
it's very often not representative of who
ultimately wins. And Steve Doocy actually
doing that analysis, which is a smart analysis and
it's an appropriate one that we should be doing,
which has not been done on Fox News. Take a
look. And his his co-hosts look visibly confused.
Speaker 2: And the first votes in the caucuses
aren't going to be until July or rather, January,
she said. In May of 2027, Romney, McCain and Rudy
were all in the top three and Mike Huckabee was
in 0%. But Mike Huckabee went on to win the Iowa
caucuses. And then in May 2015, the top three were
Walker, Rubio and Huckabee and Cruz and Trump,
who finished one and two, were not even at 10%.
Speaker 1: This is all true.
Speaker 2: So so much can happen
in Iowa. And one of the great things said.
Speaker 1: Okay, So this is absolutely
correct. And the message here is a very simple
message. The fact that Trump is so far ahead
today doesn't guarantee that Trump will be the
eventual Republican nominee. Now, it's great
that Steve Doocy is introducing some evidence into
this historical evidence that I also introduced.
His data was specifically from Iowa, where I
was talking more generally. At the same time,
it just so happens that this time around, the
circumstances are particularly unprecedented in
the sense that, yes, the leader at this point
in time isn't always the eventual nominee,
but the leader at this point in time also isn't
usually a former president in that is what we
have right now. So great for Steve Doocy to bring
these things up. The two people who sit alongside
him don't seem to know one way or the other what's
going on. Here is another example. Steve Doocy
points out correctly that Desantis's argument that
he could serve eight years if he wins in 2024,
whereas Trump would immediately be a lame duck is
absolutely true. And Steve Doocy mentions that as
well as a reason that maybe Republicans
do want to consider someone other than
Trump who would, on day one be a lame duck.
Speaker 2: Interesting. I'm not avoiding the
punch. I'll address it, but it's not going to
be my focus. And by the way, he's big into eight
years. I'm going to need more than four years
to fix this. Donald Trump can only do four. I
need eight. I'll get eight. If you get me four,
I'll get another four. If you like Donald Trump,
he can't give you another four. So that's
a legitimate tactic without alienating the
base. You know, the famous thing is whoever
beats Donald Trump, you have to beat him and
get his voters. If you beat him and lose
his voters, you can't win. But and Brian,
you make the point that we were talking about last
week, if Ron DeSantis wins, he get he can be he
can serve for two terms. But by the Constitution,
Donald Trump, who's already served one term,
can only do another. So on his first day, he
would be a lame duck. And that is one of the
considerations big donors have. And the worry
from a lot of big donors is not only does so if
Donald Trump won the primary, it's a real good
chance he would lose the White House but also
lose the House. And that's one of the problems.
Speaker 1: But listen, I mean, it's a pretty good
analysis from Steve Doocy. I have to say. It's
actually kind of like grounded in reality. I
have absolutely no idea whether this is the sort
of thing that the Fox News audience even pays
attention to when they watch Fox and Friends. Fox
and Friends is very much the type. A show that you
get to have on in the background while you're,
I don't know, making breakfast or whatever,
whatever Fox News watchers do in the morning. I
don't know that it's really getting through to
anyone. And I don't even know that Doocy is
doing this specifically to push people away
from Trump and towards Ron DeSantis. But it is
certainly a very, very interesting thing that
we are seeing. Also interesting is that some
of the Fox hosts aren't thrilled with Trump's
attacks on his own, former press secretary
Kayleigh MCENANY. Let's talk about that next.